las memorias del príncipe Harris saldrán
oficialmente a la venta este martes en
todo el mundo pero las filtraciones a la
prensa ha permitido evidenciar esa
dificilísima relación de Harry con su
padre el Rey Carlos III con su hermano
William y con Camila la reina consortea
quien llama Villana en entrevistas a
canales de televisión británicos pero
especialmente de Estados Unidos Harry
detalla el trauma que le creó a los doce
años la muerte de su mamá la princesa
Diana Quien murió en un accidente de
tránsito en París en 1997 también ha
hablado sobre la difícil aceptación y
adaptación de su esposa Meghan dentro de
la familia real y dijo que su familia
incluso ha filtrado información a los
tabloides para afectar la imagen de
Meghan Y calificó esa relación como si
su familia se metiera en la cama con el
también Harry nuevamente
reforzó esa idea casi de odio que siente
por los tabloides británicos por la
persecución que
por parte de los paparazzis desde que es
un niño y también dijo que no habla con
su padre el rey y con su hermano hace
muchísimo tiempo Lo cierto es que en el
país hay una expectativa mediana sobre
esta publicación porque el contenido del
libro ya se ha conocido ampliamente y
las grandes cadenas de librerías han
reducido el precio de 28 libras a 14
para generar que la gente lo compre en
la preventa y son unos 17 dólares Así
que veremos cómo le van las primeras
horas de venta entre tanto ni el Palacio
de boquina ni el Palacio de Kensington
se han pronunciado sobre estas
escandalosas revelaciones que ha hecho
Harry pero lo cierto Es que en algún
momento tendrán que pronunciarse por los
efectos y el daño que estas pueden
hacerle a la monarquía británica como
institución